[Music]
very important
you see baby
you know well our change freedom
[Music]
how do we actually help out
so you sit behind him
firstly
and
[Music]
[Music]
everybody hi
[Music]
who you with every birthday my question
to you is this because of all the
ventilators being
Manufacturing going on to the time Venus
- you said you think we'd have enough of
Beckham share with other countries my
question to you sir is
we're just talking about her we have a
very big stock file right now and we're
building it bigger and we're helping a
lot of other countries Nigeria we just
sent a thousand we have various various
countries France Spain we have a lot
going to Italy we have a lot going to a
different probably 15 18 countries
they're calling us we had the capacity
to do this nobody else did so every
state now has more than they need and
our stockpile is totally full we have a
tremendous amount so now we're really
helping other countries where they're
you know losing a lot of people because
they don't have ventilators a ventilator
is hard to do and I want to say that
Ford and General Electric have done an
incredible job working together and also
the companies that work with you they
really did they did a great job they do
a great car and they do they really did
a great job on the ventilator and I hear
that the quality of the ventilator has
been really the top of the line thank
you mister we really appreciated those
resident there was a lot of interest
about whether you would end up wearing
today could you just take us through
your thought process and why he decided
not well I did where I had going on
before I pour one in this back area but
I didn't want to give the press the
pleasure of seeing it but nowhere I had
it in the back area I did put say did
you have the goggles on too as well sir
here's another one because in this area
why would you think I'm not necessary
here well everybody's been tested and
I've been tested in fact I was tested
this morning but so it's not necessary
well that's interest I was given I was
given a choice and I had one on in an
area where they preferred it so I put it
on and it was very nice very nice but
they said not necessary I think it sets
an example both ways and as they say I
did have
[Music]
I just like your question so much we
know what it was such a nice question no
it's a great question because the
question for you so we've seen the
manufacturers here for small businesses
turning things how do you see what's
taking place this is the biggest
mobilization since the world war since
World War two and these people were in
charge of it they did it they did a
fantastic job they did a really
fantastic job and we appreciate it
all of these companies they came
together and they used to make cars here
they used to make other things here and
now they're not only defenseless we just
save Damascus and all of the other
programs what other product you make at
a port but not bad not a bad position
so we've got our shuttle burn I know hi
Carol hi you know we're making we've got
the the pressure respirators with
obviously the ventilators the masks the
gowns you know we really anything that
anybody needs we responded quickly and
we're very proud of our workforce
they've been amazing is he doing a good
job
crisis new year new years of chairman
CEO of the company here how does this
crisis dealing with this pandemic maybe
PP materials compare well everyone's
different I mean if they you know I
won't take you through all of them going
all the way back to you know maybe the
oil shocks and and then the you know the
dot-com meltdowns and all this every
crisis is different but what's amazing
is how our people respond and then this
one they didn't wait to be asked to do
something they said here's an
opportunity and let's go with what I
love about our culture is they didn't
ask for permission they just went and
that's something that we've done
throughout our 117 year history and I
hope we'll always do oh by the way
here's my here's my ministry and I like
it very much I absolutely I think I look
better in the man when I make any but
I'm making a speech so I won't have it
now but I did have a gun right here I
think some of you might have gotten a
shot
thank you can you confirm that the
president was told it's okay not to wear
one in this area
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the ventilator and the respirator
[Music]
so 6000 ventilators a week think of that
from a running start which wasn't much
of a run actually so we had very few in
this country almost none we were not in
that business and now they're making
thousands a week great thing
[Music]
we got to get back to the rally you
agree with that John what question is
present the rally's more question the
secretary of the Treasury said there was
a strong likelihood that we'll need
another fiscal stimulus - you're
thinking what shape would that take if
we will I think we're going to be
helping people out we're going to be
getting some money for them during the
artificial because it really is it's an
artificial closure and now we're going
to be able to open it up this isn't like
for long-term problems and then takes
years and years to having come back the
Depression took 12 years for 14 15 years
I'm gonna be back next year maybe even
in the fourth quarter in a few months
we're going to be back because look at
it we we closed it and now we open it
but I would say there could be one more
nice shot way more nice and what do you
think should be it well I'd like you
know and I have exactly I know exactly
but I'd rather do it at the appropriate
we know if they are celebrating these
great companies doing ventilators and
other equipment but we have a very very
specific plan and it'll be great for the
American people and our economy is going
to be back soon and Ford and General
Electric and these great companies that
helped us so much in a time of need
they're going to be very happy
and you're already gearing up you know I
know you're gearing up your lines is
starting to roll making cars again so a
lot of things are happening by the way
on our southern border it's never been
so secure we're up to almost 200 miles
of wall and we have never had that whole
area is nobody comes through to that
area the area where the wall goes up
that's the end of that and so you're
fearful you're having this feature this
afternoon what are you thinking about in
terms of campaign grounds when will you
be able to get back to sell as soon as
you're able to have people get in you
know we've never had an empty seat since
the day I came down the escalator with
our future first lady we've never had an
empty seat you know that and would have
thousands of people we sent away and I
think the demand half of what we see is
greater than ever before we're gonna
have to go to certain states where we're
able to look I don't want to have a
stadium where you're supposed to have a
person and then seven empty seats and
then another person so we might do some
outdoor big ones and we may also just
wait till the stadium's can open up I
think it's going to be soon we'll go to
a place like Florida we'll go to a place
like maybe Georgia or some other place
where they're going to be opening up
whoever it opens up first the demand has
been incredible to get going with the
rallies they just hear the music in the
background I'm saying we've done rallies
like nobody's ever had and we would love
to get back to that I think it's going
to be sooner
you were asked about this briefly this
morning this name AstraZeneca backs TEM
Oxford that HHS has invested 1 billion
dollars in how much promise do you think
that holds for an early vaccination I
think it also Mendes promise but we have
many of the companies who are just about
as far along we have many companies we
have the greatest pharmaceutical
companies in the world they're equally
you know I mean they're really in a
position and I'm only I'm not only
talking about vaccine I'm talking about
cures and therapeutics therapeutically
we have some things coming out which we
think is going to be great for them to
be tested quickly anyway we're doing it
very quick who would get the vaccine
first first responders elderly be right
now what we're doing is we're setting
what logistically with our military our
military is in gear so that we can give
150 200 million shots quickly the
militaries in gear you know we can move
a couple of hundred thousand soldiers
immediately in time of emergency so this
is not nearly as big a deal is that
it's equally as important perhaps but
it's not it's not as tough logistical
but how would you prioritize it I'll sit
down with a lot of people who will
figure it out we're going to sit down
with a military and we hope to be in
that position fairly soon so rather than
having the vaccine doing the tests and
then starting to gear up we're taking a
risk because you know it could be that
if something happened but I don't think
that's going to be but in addition to
that company we have other companies
that are very far advanced and also
don't forget therapeutics and cure we're
talking about a vaccine in this case and
therapeutics
and frankly that's my first choice
because that would take care of people
that are in trouble right now
mr. president on the issue of testing
there's a question about whether you're
satisfied or not with what the CDC is
doing the work they're doing
particularly the director dr. Fran field
can you address that
are you satisfied I think we're doing a
good job a really good job in a very
complex situation you know we started
off nobody knew what the virus was it
came in from China nobody knew what it
was and frankly I think they've done a
really good job I'm very happy about it
a lot of other people think they've done
a lot of you know great work we're now
up to and this is beyond even CDC
because we've done it between Jared
Kushner and a lot of geniuses coming in
from Silicon Valley and a lot of people
these companies where they could make
ventilators and or look what we did with
ventilators is incredible because we
dared up in a short period of time
through General Electric Ford they're
represented here at the top level
through other companies we were at
Honeywell the other day they make masks
who would think Honeywell is making a
mask but that's what they're making now
is a mask it's a very high tech company
you know they make the the dashboards to
an airplane other things that now
they're making mist our company's geared
up so quickly so fast
Honeywell open to plant in three weeks
from literally zero to open making
masters and three websites it's been an
incredible achievement there's never
been anything done like this since the
end of
you said to set a number of weeks ago we
can't let the Cure become word that's
too early disease where are where are we
in that company I think I was the first
one to say it I don't know when you say
that I was the first one but you can't
let the Cure become worse than the
problem itself there were I think we
have to I think the governor's have to
start opening up we now know the disease
we know the weaknesses and the strengths
we know that older people are affected
gravely and younger people are not
affected gravely frankly you look at the
statistics it's incredible and we know
that we have to protect some people much
more so I think a lot of the governor's
have done a very very poor job or
nursing homes but they've done a good
job on other things I know every
governor I can give you I can grade
every governor but we've made a lot of
euro comforters we've done a great job
for the governors and my relationship
with them in almost all cases is very
good and remember this one of the
beauties we just document not one person
who needed a ventilator didn't get a
ventilator but with another 2.4 million
people claiming first-time unemployment
benefits today how close are we to the
cure being worse than the disease I
think that a lot of these states are
going to have the ones in earth sort of
sticking to a certain very rigid manner
I think they're gonna stop I don't think
the people are gonna stand for it this
is a country that's meant to be open not
closed and we did the right thing John
we saved millions of lives millions and
billions of lives you would have had
anywhere from a million five to two
million five three million lives think
of it so if we were at a hundred
thousand instead of a hundred thousand
multiply that times 15 20 or 25 it
wouldn't have been acceptable it
wouldn't have been sustainable he
couldn't have done it so we've called it
right and now I want it open and we're
going to open and if there's a fire and
ember a flame someplace we put it out
but the people have done a great job and
General Electric for did all the other
people that work with them have done
fantastic work and Honeywell again I was
there last week but Honeywell they've
done fantastically well thank you Bert
people say that's a very distinct
possibility its standard and we're going
to put out the fires we're not going to
close the country we're going to put out
the fires it could be whether it's an
ember or a flame we're going to put it
out but we're not closing